bonsoir bonsoir bonjour
la semaine
bonjour la gauche a défilé tout le
week-end à la Fête de l'Huma c'était la
88e édition ce weekend trois jours de
concert et de débats parfois chahuté par
exemple entre le communiste Fabien
Roussel et l'ancien Premier ministre
Édouard Philippe voici ce qui s'est
passé juste avant le début du débat
Édouard Philippe a ses vies durant le
moment des gilets jaunes il a fait
couler le sang il n'a rien à faire ici
c'est un épargneur c'est un nez
order
depuis la Fête de l'Humanité Sandrine
Rousseau a adressé une nouvelle pique au
communiste Fabien Roussel sur un sujet
qui fait débat à gauche la consommation
de viande écoutée nous n'avons pas
minimiser les effets que peuvent avoir
nos pollutions nos consommations sur la
mise en danger de chacun
[Musique]